zero points do basic real turns the
split Time same direction wall plane POI
plane orientation POI spinning has so
much jargon in it how do you filter
through what all the different things
mean and what are the most important
terms to know
I got you covered Drex here from
drexfactor POI sharing with you the love
of poi spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and today we're
going to talk about the top five most
important Concepts to understand in POI
spinning I'm going to decode some of
this so that y'all out there can come
into our world and enjoy it but before
we dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyro
Terra light toys spin balls and Ultra
POI for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lane machinski and Becca
becklinen thank you both so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission
so straight up I know that it can be
pretty frustrating to watch POI videos
especially mine if you don't know what
all of these big words mean third order
motion anti-brid continuous assembly
pattern it just seems to be sometimes an
impenetrable wall of really big words
that don't really make this world feel
all that terribly friendly to somebody
who's just coming into it so as a
thought exercise I decided to whittle
down what I think are the top five most
important Concepts in all of poi
spinning stuff that if you don't have
that idea in your head you're going to
have a really difficult time with pretty
much anything in the POI world I kind of
figured this was both a good way to
extract some signal from the noise as
well as a good exercise for me and
knowing what I can and cannot leave out
when I talk about POI now it goes
without saying that any such list is
going to be controversial and there are
going to be people that think that there
are particular topics within the POI
world that Merit inclusion here I'm
doing my best here and I hope that it
will help some other people out there
feel a little bit more comfortable in
this world and have a little bit more of
it decoded for them so
so let's go ahead and dive in
concept number one POI plane orientation
so straight up if you have heard people
discuss POI at all you've probably heard
them use the word planes planes of
course are just how we Define the
orientation of how the POI is spinning
as it relates to our body and it's
really important because we want to try
and keep our POI cleanly inside of those
planes so when we talk about POI planes
and plane orientation really what we're
doing is we're thinking about the
movement of the POI as it spins as
essentially defining a flat surface like
a plate and that plate can be oriented
relative to our body in any one of three
major Fashions it could be wall plane
where it's even with us as we're facing
in a given Direction it could be wheel
plane as though it's a pair of wagon
wheels on the side of us or it could be
horizontal plane where it's basically
flat against the floor or ceiling once
you know what to look for with this
you'll realize that we tend to train
people to spin POI almost exclusively in
wall plane it's kind of an unspoken rule
of poised spinning but it's something
that means that the audience gets the
fullest profile of the POI as they spin
around the performer's body if you want
a more thorough lesson on what POI
planes are and how we Define them I will
go ahead and leave a link to a video
tutorial I did on that very topic down
in the description as well as up in the
cards if you're watching on YouTube
POI concept number two timing and
direction
so timing and direction is another one
of those terms that is really long and
intimidating but basically what it means
is we're talking about how POI move
relative to each other and the kinds of
symmetry that they produce in the
process currently we recognize four
major modes of timing and direction
together same in which the POI and hands
are essentially producing exactly the
same pattern side by side in effect
doubling the appearance of that pattern
together opposite in which the hands and
POI separate on either side and come
together at the top and bottom this
results in patterns that appear to
reflect across a vertical axis of
symmetry split Time same direction in
which the hands and POI are always at
opposite ends of the same Circle this
produces patterns that always appear to
be reflecting across a constantly
changing axis of symmetry or a point in
the very center and split time opposites
in which the hands and POI separate top
and bottom and come back together to
either side this results in patterns
that appear to reflect across a
horizontal axis of symmetry I know it
seems like kind of a lot of information
to absorb so here's the Cliff's Notes
does the pattern double it's together
same does it reflect like a butterfly or
bird's wings it's together opposite does
it look like a swimmer performing the
crawl stroke it's split same and does it
reflect like the Horizon on a lake that
is split opposites deal with that what
you will for those of you who are
interested there has actually been an
attempt to try to simplify our
terminology around timing and Direction
and just correlate each of the modes
with a classic Greek element so together
same winds up being Earth together
opposite winds up being air split Time
same direction winds up being water and
of course split time opposites winds up
being fire if that works for you go
ahead and use it personally I don't find
it that intuitive overall but it has
definitely found some use with a lot of
people cool so we got the two biggest
and most obvious ones out of the way so
now I'm going to drill down into some
more esoteric stuff that is really
important to understand with POI but I
feel like we don't talk about all that
often starting with
concept number three plane facing
so what exactly is plane facing
basically there's a weird property to
When You Spin POI if you're on one side
of the plane it appears that the POI is
going to be spinning One Direction and
if you're on the other side of the plane
it appears it's spinning the opposite
direction basically which direction the
POI is spinning in largely depends on
which side of the plane you happen to be
on this can be really confusing to us as
humans because we can set any direction
to be forwards for us the idea that if
we walk around a thing it changes
Direction on us seems really
counter-intuitive and truth be told when
I first started to learn how to spin POI
one of my first lessons was how to do
basic real turns that is turning from
the POI going forwards to the POI going
reverse and I could not understand this
for the life of me partially because I
just expected the POI to be going
whichever way I was and it was very very
odd to me that the POI just didn't want
to cooperate in that regard this is an
aspect of poi spinning that is so
important to learn because basically it
becomes impossible to move through a
space with the prop without keeping this
in mind you have to learn how to
intuitively switch your awareness of
which direction the POI plane is
spinning depending upon where you happen
to be in relation to it this can take a
lot of training to achieve and it's
something that we all struggle with at
various points in our POI journey and as
far as I know it's a term that didn't
exist until I was several years into my
POI Journey it seems so odd to me that
something that is such a basic fact of
how the POI moves is something that we
had such a hard time putting a name to
for so long but we have a name for it
now so make sure that this is Central to
your understanding of the prop
concept number four zero points
so zero point is really just a fancy
name for anything you do with the POI
that makes it stop even for a split
second so think of things like stalls
and pendulums things that involve having
the POI completely arrest all of its
momentum for a moment and then you can
choose to either reverse the direction
of it or keep it still depending upon
what you want to do there zero points
are essential for most transitions as
well as things like plane breaking they
pop up more often than you might think
and frequently they exist purely as a
thing unto themselves one of my favorite
techniques that I've picked up over the
years is to use zero points as a way to
Accent the beat in the music that I'm
dancing to lots of people when they're
first learning POI will focus on
learning individual tricks as though
they are unique Concepts unto themselves
that just kind of sit in isolation from
each other and then wind up in a place
where they have to ask well how exactly
do I get back and forth between them
zero points in all of their various
permutations really are the answer
almost all the time zero points become
come integral for switching timing and
direction in different POI patterns as
well as doing wild intermediate and
advanced stuff like stacking it's a big
word that really just means make the POI
stop moving for a second so you can
switch which direction it's going in
that's it and now before I reveal the
final POI concept that I've stuck on
this list I have a favor to ask if
you've come this far it probably means
that you've got an interest in POI
spinning or more broadly in the flow
arts and if so I have good news for you
because I like to make lots of videos
about POI spinning and flow Arts so if
you could go ahead and leave a like And
subscribe to the channel so that you
know the next time I upload a video
thanks in advance and now my final pick
for the top five most important POI
Concepts we have
POI concept number five POI Lanes
so this is actually a concept that I got
to name myself back in the day but it's
actually really simple the idea being
that if you have two objects that are
spinning in such a way that they would
normally run into each other how do you
keep them from doing so well the answer
turns out to be you think of the space
between them as being like a two-lane
road and you make sure that one of those
objects is in one lane and the other
object is in another and because modern
POI spinning focuses so much on keeping
the POI flat in wall plane this is a
technique that comes in really handy a
lot more often than you would think not
just in Split Time same direction but in
a whole lot of other timing and
Direction modes too honestly the way I
kind of like to think of this is that
it's a little bit analogous to what
happens when dancers get trained namely
that they get trained to rest their body
in specific shapes likewise we want to
have our body instinctively find spots
where we're going to be able to separate
our planes with a little bit of depth as
we're spending them in front of us in
wall plane here this is one of those
things that I try to teach to people as
soon as possible because especially when
it comes to intermediate and advanced
POI this winds up being a fundamental
concept that you just cannot go very far
without getting down so those are my
picks for the top five most important
Concepts in POI spinning I hope that
this has managed to decode some stuff
for those of you out there that are just
getting into this world and for those of
you who've been in this world for a
while how many of these Concepts did you
know and are there any concepts that
didn't make my list that you think
should have also if you like the way
that I break down knowledge and would
like to learn more POI from Maine I have
a beginner POI course available over on
mylearning site at learn.drexfactor.com
you can sign up for that at five percent
off by using the discount code five
Concepts at checkout I hope you all
enjoy checking those out and pretty
please I hope to see more people out
there exploring the POI world as a
result
[Music]
thank you
this video would not be possible we're
not for the kind support of all of these
awesome people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description helped to make this video
and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you all so very much for
your very generous support and if you
out there watching are not currently
supporter but you'd like to become one
you can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com drexfactor POI and signing
up you can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better than
that you'll be helping me out in
creating content like this to bring POI
spinning and flow Arts to the whole wide
world so go check that out please and
thank you and if you'd like to check out
some of my beginner POI lessons that
I've recorded over the years I will go
ahead and leave a link to a playlist of
those videos down in the description as
well as up here on screen if you are
watching on YouTube also the YouTube
algorithm thinks that you might like
this top video here because it's been
really popular amongst viewers of my
channel so maybe give that a look as
well thanks so much for watching make
sure to adopt and flow today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon
peace